the canyon speedmax sf
time trial bike this year's winner of
germany's national design award
professional triathlete marcos farcbach
has been training on this
state-of-the-art two-wheeler
since july two thousand twelve
the familiar sport is a situation for me
as an athlete it has to be
fast not just look fast
the canyon bicycles team nominated in
the lifestyle category
were not expecting to win at the high
profile ceremony in berlin
the government sponsored award is
considered the most prestigious accolade
in the german design world
is based in the western german city of
kublenz
in giving the award the jury cited its
innovative frame architecture
straight contours and lightweight look
it costs up to 9000 euros and was
specially developed for use in
professional competition
we want the bike to convey a message
ideally the visualization of pure speed
the bike is made for extreme demands so
it's important to reflect that in the
design
we want to evoke a reaction
a time trial bike is a precision
instrument not a fashion accessory
on the road victory and defeat can be
decided by a fraction of a second
as cyclist thomas figal himself knows
but his focus was on the appearance
working with engineers also needs an
edge
you need points of friction otherwise
we'd have a very limited scope for
innovation
we challenge the engineer's creativity
with our ideas
which sometimes goes beyond the
objective in our season
canyon bicycles has a workforce of over
300
the speedmax is produced exclusively in
koblenz
the development phase took two years and
it was another 12 months before the
finished product was launched
industrial engineer wolfgang cool faced
the task of turning the designer's
blueprint
into a working bicycle
i'm spinning xcf it wasn't hard to
realize
the requirements of the design
early on in the project we noticed that
the ideas of the designer were highly
compatible with our notion of
aerodynamics
this bike is a high high-tech instrument
the frame is made of lightweight carbon
fiber
prior to construction it was tested with
computer tomography technology
to detect any potential material faults
the cables are inside the bike further
enhancing its aerodynamic design
the material also had to withstand a
range of stress tests
the speedmax has chalked up other prizes
as well including the prestigious red
dot design award
the back's designers also wanted the
individual components to be adjustable
to the rider
like the seat
speedmax as creators are convinced that
the design has an impact on performance
don't forget there's also an emotional
aspect for riders
even in the tour of halls if a rider
thinks he's on a fast bike
which he can see but not measure then
he'll become quicker
we've created a kind of placebo effect
for cycling design
marcus covers the standard triathlon
cycling distance of 180 kilometers
in four and a half hours the speedmax sf
combines form and function the second
generation is already in the pipeline
and is likewise sure to be a contender
on the road and
in the design community